now here's the best one of all of them
this is
MSNBC contributor Claire mccaskill
former she was former senator from where
where's she from again Claire mccaskill
where was she from like Idaho or where
was she from
I don't want to blame the good people
who live there Missouri
a fine State the great state of Missouri
they they she's no longer the senator uh
here she is she's an MSNBC contributor
telling everybody just get off Joe's
back leave Joe alone
cynical bet that nobody nobody views
this as a normal family nobody knows
that the bidens have dealt with loss and
pain what do you make of the fact that
David Jolly's point that they should
take this loss and move on find another
political weapon to wield
what America they live in
um and I don't know how they sleep at
night
you know alcoholism and addiction are
probably the most pervasive diseases in
America I don't know of one family
that hasn't been touched
by the pain
of these diseases
and it's particularly painful when you
have someone you love unconditionally
that is suffering from these diseases
and by the way everybody needs to back
off Joe Biden about this he loves his
son back off it is okay for him to love
his son and there's nothing wrong with
it they have no evidence of any kind of
wrongdoing by Joe Biden and it
infuriates me that they're using this
heartbreak against Joe Biden in this way
it's just not right she is a perfect
leftist she's a perfect leftist nothing
she said there has anything to do with
the law everything she said there had to
do with pulling heartstrings but really
pulling them sort of in the wrong
direction right like no one's saying
that Joe Biden can't love his son no
one's saying don't have sympathy for
people that are hooked on alcohol and
drugs right we all know somebody that's
been affected by alcohol and drugs we've
all had our our own struggles whatever
it might be nobody's saying any of that
the issue here first off what they got
him on was tax evasion but the issues
all the other stuff that I've now
repeated Ad nauseam for the 20 minutes
or so that we've been doing this
the idea that this has nothing to do
with Joe Biden that's what she
repeatedly is saying there this has
nothing to do with Joe Biden lady Claire
mccaskill I tweeted this at you
yesterday so now I will repeat it on
video and people can cut it and send it
to you Claire mccaskill who was vice
president when crackhead Hunter Biden
got a job for eighty thousand dollars a
year at a Ukrainian Energy company with
no qualifications
his name is Joe Biden he's the president
now do you think that a Ukrainian Energy
company might want to give a job to a
guy who might have access to the vice
president so that they could get some
sort of deal pulled off does that seem
too crazy to you or am I just being mean
you tell me
[Music]
thank you